en arrivant ils ne se sont même pas
serré la main et dès la deuxième
question du débat la polémique du week
end entre en jeu et nous l'avons vu
violer les femmes en se basant sur leur
apparence les jacente à 10 quand je dois
te parler
je me dis que le populisme c'est pas la
défense du peuple
contrairement à ce que réclament
toujours tous les populistes c'est le
mépris du peuple
moi je ne suis pas fier de ce que j'ai
dit mais c'était quelque chose qui s'est
passé si vous regardez et il s'est
comporté beaucoup plus mal que moi par
quelques minutes avant ce deuxième débat
le milliardaire a donné une conférence
de presse autour de lui plusieurs femmes
qui affirment avoir été violées par
l'ancien président des états unis
j'entends de tels propos ça me rappelle
le conseil de mon amie michelle obama
quand il frappe en dessous de la
ceinture il faut frapper au dessus des
600 ch deux types political campaign
je n'ai jamais vu j'espère bien pas une
politique aussi ça que je travaillais
quand j'espère bien que jamais une
campagne française de tombera à ce
niveau digne monsieur le maire vous êtes
le maire d'où la mission que vous
donnerez pause coppito comme une
personne en regroupement familial en
haut le regroupement familial c'est
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes parents ses 12000 à plusieurs
centaines de milliers surtout sur le
mandat pour kant ou trump c'est le
morano en santiags ça vous fait sourire
oh je trouve ça presque vous êtes
plongés dans ce dossier vous en parlez
sans savoir sans connaître c'est ce que
nous reprochons responsables politiques
leur groupe c'est qu'il ne sait rien
est-ce que vous connaîtriez le petit
artisan qui fabrique des gamelles en
france parce que je pense reprendre une
avance du maire de bordeaux et de 14
points sur son concurrent nicolas
sarkozy 42% d'intentions de vote
contre 28% pour l'ancien président au
second tour les chiffre monte même
jusqu'à 62% pour alain juppé a non
seulement j'y crois encore mais je
m'interroge si vous voulez sur la
qualité des des sondages je dis pas que
les sondages se trompent tout le temps
je pense que pour la primaire choses
sont compliquées
trente mille euros à nice en 2012 on a
vu cette rangée de soi de projecteur qui
éclairait la femme une rangée de
projecteurs tricolore et si on compare
avec pierre tu vois ça fait pas
forcément le même effet pour lui pour
ça c'était officiellement le même prix
trente mille euros les 2 donkey hérissé
faire arnaquer lui demandait et puis à
lutter on va pas désigné les nuits tout
fait on n'a pas dit la vérité est une et
c'est nous qui l'avons on m'a simplement
dit que pour construire cette société de
demain
il fallait l'effort de tous et la
participation de tous voilà pourquoi je
suis venu